Vaccines, in general, have
been a massive boon to humanity.
They’ve rid the world of an affliction that
has plagued humanity for thousands of years
in smallpox (for reference killing over 300
million people in the 20th century alone before
it was eradicated), and have almost completely
wiped out polio, all while preventing millions
of deaths from countless other viruses every
single year.
As for the flu vaccine, it’s recommended
by the Center for Disease Control and Prevention
(CDC), the National Institute of Health, and
almost every other major health organization
around the world.
Despite this, outside of whether certain vaccines
can give babies autism (see our article: Do
Vaccines Cause Autism?), few vaccines garner
as much controversy as the flu vaccine.
So if vaccines are so great- and they unequivocally
are, assuming you’re not a “watch the
world burn” type- and the flu vaccine is
so widely recommended by experts, why is there
such controversy surrounding it?
Today we’ll be doing a deep dive on this
topic, as well as answering the question of
whether the flu vaccine can give you the flu.
According the US census bureau, there are
approximately 320 million people in the United
States.
The CDC states that about 20% of the population
will be affected by the flu each year, and
in 2013 in the U.S. there were around 57,000
deaths caused by influenza/pneumonia, with
the CDC crediting 3,697 as dying from influenza
specifically.
In fact, in that same year the CDC reported
that the flu was number eight on the top causes
of death behind (in order) heart disease,
cancer, chronic lower respiratory diseases,
accidents, strokes, Alzheimer’s, and diabetes.
It is estimated that if every person in the
United States received a flu shot, it would
cost approximately $4.8 billion and would
save approximately 3,200 lives each year on
top of what are already saved today at current
vaccination levels, all while preventing around
a whopping 100,000 hospitalizations.
As with everything, there’s a trade-off,
however; this is, in part, where some of the
controversy starts to creep in.
In this case, if everyone were vaccinated,
around a total of 320-640 people each year
would hospitalized, suffer a life threatening
illness, be permanently disabled or die as
a result of the vaccine.
On top of that, around 3.2 million per year
of the total 320 million could potentially
have an immune reaction causing flu-like symptoms,
although more minor than the actual flu itself
and the hard number on this latter point is
somewhat up for debate.
(It may actually be smaller, which we’ll
get into later.)
To better understand these numbers and the
controversy surrounding them, let’s look
at what the flu is, why the flu vaccine doesn’t
always seem to work, and the problems associated
with creating vaccines to fight this particular
deliverer-of-death.
The influenza virus is a member of the virus
family Orthomyxoviridae and comes in four
broad flavors- Type A, B, C and D. The flu
vaccine is designed to protect you from A,
B, and C. Type D will usually affect cattle
and hasn’t been shown to infect people.
Type A and B are the two usually causing seasonal
epidemics, and they’re the two classes of
viruses the seasonal vaccine is designed to
protect you from.
Type C will most likely cause mild respiratory
illnesses and aren’t thought to be a cause
of epidemics.
Type A has two subtypes; they are differentiated
by the type of protein they have on the surface
of the virus, Hemagglutinin or Neuraminidase.
Hemagglutinin also comes in 18 different varieties
and Neuraminidasse has 11; these are named
H1-18 and N1-11.
Combined, these classes can make up strains.
Influenza type A strains are H1N1 and H3N2.
(In 2009, you might have been aware of the
specific H1N1 virus.
Prior to that year, H1N1 viruses circulating
around the populous caused their normal web-of-woe.
Unfortunately, a new strain of H1N1 began
circulating causing worsened symptoms and
was the first known flu pandemic in about
four decades.)
Type B viruses are characterized by lineage,
depending on the type of antibody they produce-
Type B/Yamagata and type B/Victoria.
The annual flu vaccine will attempt to give
you immunity from both H1N1 and H3N2 type
A viruses, and either 1 or 2 of the type B.
As previously alluded to, no current seasonal
vaccine attempts to prevent type C.
This brings us to why flu vaccinations don’t
always work.
Due to the extremely large number of specific
flu viruses, and the complexities in figuring
out which ones are circulating, it’s nearly
impossible to create a vaccine that will protect
everyone from every type of virus.
Instead, scientists will create annual flu
vaccines depending on the most likely type
of flu that will be circulating that year.
How do they figure out which flu virus is
more likely to be circulating?
There are over 100 countries that have national
influenza centers conducting year-round surveillance
for flu.
They send their results to five main World
Health Organization research centers in Atlanta,
London, Melbourne, Tokyo, and Beijing.
Two times per year (in February for the Northern
Hemisphere and September for the Southern)
representatives from each research center
meet up and review the results of studies
looking at surveillance issues, laboratory
results and clinical studies.
They also asses the availability of vaccine
viruses.
After analyzing all the data, they make recommendations
for the composition of the next flu vaccine.
Based on those recommendations, each individual
country decides on the specific composition
of the viruses included in their vaccines.
(In the United States, the FDA makes the final
decision on vaccines to be sold in the U.S.
and the CDC collects data from five sites
across the country to assess how well the
vaccine is working.)
There are two main types of flu vaccines,
Trivalent and quadrivalent.
The former is so-named “Tri” because it
protects you from three types of the flu-
type A H1N1 and H3N2, and one of the B viruses;
it could be either one.
As for the latter quadrivalent, it simply
adds the second type of B antigen to the mix.
(For reference, of the estimated 157-168 million
doses of vaccine available for the 2016-2017
flu season in the United States, about 96
million were quadrivalent.)
The two types of vaccines are made in one
of three ways.
Most use egg based manufacturing processes-
they inject viruses into fertilized hen’s
eggs and allow them to incubate for several
days.
The viruses are then removed, killed, and
the antigens purified.
That concoction is now a flu vaccine.
More recently, the FDA has allowed these viruses
to be just severely weakened, instead of killed.
This allows for the vaccine to be produced
as a nasal spray instead of injected.
(However, for the 2016-2017 flu season the
CDC issued a recommendation that this latter
form of flu vaccination not be used owing
to data showing it to be significantly less
effective compared to other forms of flu vaccines
between 2013-2016, and non-effective altogether
during the 2015-2016 flu season.)
Cell based vaccines use pretty much the same
process as the egg based manufacturing, except
mammalian cells are called on to incubate
the virus instead of eggs.
The third method uses recombinant technology.
In a nutshell, they take the protein on the
surface of the virus and combine it with portions
of other viruses that grow well inside insect
cells.
Allowed to multiply inside the insect cells,
the proteins from the original virus are harvested
and purified for release as a vaccine.
No matter which method used, outside of potentially
the relatively rarely administered nasal spray
version, the vaccine will give you some level
of protection against the flu.
With that background out of the way, we’ll
now address the question of the hour- Can
the flu vaccine give you the flu?
As you might have guessed already given our
description of how flu vaccines are made,
the answer is unequivocally no- you’re not
going to get the flu from the flu vaccine.
Beyond the process itself being perfected,
extensive testing is done on the vaccine batches
themselves to ensure no viable virus ever
runs the gauntlet and finds its way into the
solution injected into you.
This fact is also backed up by countless studies
looking at those who receive flu vaccines.
So why are so many convinced that the flu
vaccine can give you the flu?
As previously noted, the flu vaccine can,
and commonly does, give you symptoms caused
by an immune response.
(An immune response is what you’re hoping
for in the first place.)
That stimulation can come with its own side
effects.
For instance, people may experience soreness,
swelling around the injection site, muscle
and joint pain, hives, rash, headache, nausea,
general feelings of weakness, etc. from the
flu vaccine.
If this sounds eerily like the symptoms the
flu gives you, you’re correct.
Usually, however, even if such a reaction
does take place, it is generally much less
severe than the actual flu itself.
For reference here, in 2015, 86-92% of people
who received the flu vaccine reported redness
around the injection site; 50-59% said they
had swelling; and 33-45% said itching was
also a problem.
Beyond the injection site, 9-15 % say they
felt generally ill after getting the shot,
while 10-13% said a headache also occurred.
That said, particularly these latter numbers
need taken with a grain of salt.
As the CDC points out, a portion of them appear
to fall in line with the chance of becoming
sick from every day things we come across
at any given point, like other viruses, bacteria,
fungi, etc.
So, for example, said individual may get infected
by one of the couple hundred or so viruses
that cause the “common cold” around the
time they get the flu vaccine, and go on to
think that the vaccine gave them the flu or
flu-like symptoms.
In fact, in one study with a sample size of
about two thousand people, half were given
a saline shot (salt-water) and half actual
flu vaccines, with the result being the two
groups reporting almost identical subsequent
symptoms, with the exception being that those
given the actual flu shots had more soreness
near the injection site- the important thing
for the discussion at hand being that those
who reported “flu-like” symptoms (and
all other excepting arm soreness) after getting
the shot did so just as frequently whether
they got the saline solution or flu vaccine.
Needless to say, it’s difficult to determine
precisely how many people who report flu-like
symptoms after receiving the flu vaccine have
such symptoms because of the vaccine- correlation
does not equal causation, no matter how much
our brains seem pre-wired to think so.
No matter what the precise numbers really
are- a very small percentage of people are
generally thought to have a reaction to the
flu shot that more or less feels to them like
the flu, perhaps leading someone to think
they got the flu from the flu shot, even though
they have not.
In another scenario, similar to when acquiring
a virus that gives you the “common cold”
around the time of receiving the flu shot,
someone might legitimately get the flu directly
before or after getting the flu shot.
In this case, however, it wasn’t the shot
that gave them the flu; they either just acquired
the live, full strength virus before their
immune system had a chance to work its magic
on the vaccine (which takes about two weeks)
or they acquired a strain of the virus the
vaccine didn’t help with.
These factors combined have led to the widespread
idea that the flu vaccine can cause a person
to get the flu, despite a significant amount
of scientifically vetted evidence to the contrary.
Again, it’s always good to keep in mind
that correlation does not equal causation.
And after forming such opinions, this is one
of many times when one might need to fight
a bit against the brain’s natural tendency
towards confirmation bias and just look at
what the significant amount of hard data says
instead.
This may all have you wondering how the flu
vaccine protects you from the flu at all given
in the vast majority of cases you’re having
dead viruses injected.
In a nutshell, vaccines work because they
trick your immune system into thinking there
is a live virus present in the body.
As for the much more interesting nitty gritty
details, your adaptive immune system has two
types of cells, B and T cells, that seek out
and destroy these viruses.
B cells produce unique protein molecules (antibodies)
that attach to receptor sites of antigens
(in this case the flu vaccine).
Once attached, they act like a red flag for
T cells to recognize.
Once identified, your immune system will immediately
begin creating large numbers of identical
cells to circulate throughout your body.
They mobilize like a defending army and attempt
to vanquish the enemy.
Should your immune-infantry succeed, memory
B and T cells will hang around for a while
in case the same invader shows up later.
It’s these memory B and T cells that the
vaccine is attempting to create within your
body.
If you get vaccinated and your body creates
its memory B and T cells, when the actual
flu rears its ugly head, you have the adaptive
immunity to prevent the virus from being able
to replicate and spread throughout your body.
Once you’re injected with a vaccine, as
previously mentioned, it’ll usually take
about two weeks for your immune system to
work its magic and create the antibodies necessary
to fight off a future flu attack.
With the peak of flu season between December
and February (see Why Do People Seem to Get
Sick More in the Winter), you want to get
the vaccine in the early fall, giving your
immune system enough time to mobilize before
you’re potentially exposed.
This brings us around to the question of how
effective flu vaccines actually are.
This varies considerably from year to year
based on how well matched a given year’s
vaccine is for the strains of virus circulating,
but according the CDC, from 2004-2015, the
flu vaccine was effective 61% of the time
against H1N1 and 33% effective against H3N2.
Against type B, they were 54% effective.
(It should also be noted that even if not
fully effective, the symptoms a vaccinated
person experiences may be somewhat less severe
than those who are not vaccinated.)
This said, as you now know, there are many
types of influenza viruses.
The symptoms they cause are wide-ranging,
from mild to deadly.
Some people seek treatment for their symptoms,
and many more do not.
Many other types of illnesses can cause similar
symptoms, leading many to say they have the
flu when they, in fact, do not.
Combined with the fact that to specifically
diagnose the flu you need to have your blood
drawn and a lab confirm it was the flu that
caused your symptoms, it can be extremely
difficult for researchers to nail down the
exact numbers of those affected, which is
why quoted numbers can, in some cases, vary
a bit from study to study.
This caveat noted, as previously alluded to,
the general consensus is that the flu causes
between 3,000 and 49,000 deaths and 200,000
hospitalizations per year in the United States
alone.
The flu vaccine is currently the best weapon
doctors have of preventing its spread, and
its symptoms-of-suffering.
The biggest concern for opponents of the flu
vaccine is whether it should be recommended
for everyone.
(Many companies, mostly in the health industry,
even require it as a condition of employment.)
Whatever side of the argument one is on, few
would dispute that the flu vaccine isn’t
as effective as we humans would like.
Generally speaking, as previously mentioned,
getting a flu vaccine is close to a coin flip
in preventing you from getting the flu.
And unfortunately, those who it’s most intended
to protect- those over 65 and children under
2- seem to get the least protection from it.
In fact, surprisingly, one of the largest
studies performed on flu vaccine effectiveness
by age group in the United States, published
in the Journal of Infectious Disease in May
of 2015, Influenza Vaccine Effectiveness in
the United States During 2012–2013: Variable
Protection by Age and Virus Type, showed almost
no effectiveness for those over 65.
(However, there is some evidence that newer
high-dose flu vaccines may lead to a stronger
immune response in the elderly, potentially
changing the numbers a bit, with further research
needed.)
As for healthy adults and older children,
they see the most benefit from the vaccine.
Ironically, they’re also the least likely
to have serious medical complications from
getting the flu to begin with.
So why is it recommended that these individuals
get the flu vaccine at all then?
Because, even given all this, studies have
shown that for every 4000 people vaccinated
against the flu, one person’s life will
be saved.
The CDC also points out that herd immunity
helps prevent the flu’s widespread transmission.
Essentially, if enough people get the vaccine,
there will be a large portion of the populous
that are immune to given strains; so when
the flu does start to spread, there will be
less of a chance of it affecting the population
at large.
So those elderly who it would appear the vaccine
isn’t particularly effective for will at
least get some level of protection via being
less likely to encounter the flu if most everyone
around them is vaccinated against the projected
major strains of the virus in a given year.
Given this, how are there still any real opponents
to flu vaccination?
Beyond those using faulty data and/or questionable
logic, or just being generally anti-vaccine
regardless of what any data says, there are
some who have more legitimate concerns.
While you may not get the flu from the flu
vaccine, we said near the beginning of this
article that some people die from getting
the flu shot- a much worse prospect altogether.
So what’s going on here?
Like any immune response, there are those
who can have an over-reaction to the flu vaccine.
Although extremely rare, the CDC states serious
reactions- those defined as causing hospitalization,
life threatening illness, permanent disability
or death- occur in 1-2 people for every 1
million vaccinated.
Yes, an almost literal case of “a one in
a million shot.”
In the words of Lloyd Christmas from Dumb
and Dumber, “So your telling me there’s
a chance?!?!”
Another condition, known as Guillain-Barré
syndrome occurs in about 1 person per million
vaccinated.
This condition is where your immune system
attacks your nerves leaving you with symptoms
ranging from tingling and numbness and can
lead to overall paralysis.
(This said, a 2009 study in China looking
at the administration of over 100 million
doses of flu vaccine found only 0.1 cases
of Guillain-Barré per million, which was
oddly lower, not higher, than what would be
expected of the general population who weren’t
vaccinated.)
Nevertheless, this is still widely cited as
an exceptionally rare serious side effect
of widespread use of flu vaccines, even though
recent studies are beginning to cast some
doubt on this notion.
If you’re starting to get a good picture
on why getting a flu shot is such a hot topic,
despite it being a net positive to society
as a whole, there’s actually more wood to
throw on the fire.
Some studies show that repeated vaccinations
will reduce vaccine effectiveness later on.
So- get vaccinated now when you’re healthy
and in your prime, potentially helping young
children and the elderly in the process, if
not yourself, and you could have less effectiveness
as you age and start to really need the help
from the vaccine.
It should be noted though that there is more
research that needs done here, as there are
also studies using valid methodology that
don’t seem to show these results.
(Again, going back to how difficult it is
to nail down precise numbers here without
very expensive studies with massive sample-sizes
or just a huge number of studies being done
looking at something.)
So the question of repeated dosing is still
up in the air and in need of further research.
Nevertheless, opponents of the flu vaccine
posit that since over half of the time the
effectiveness of the vaccine is less than
50% it may not be worth it to take even a
one in a million chance of being a person
who has a severe reaction.
On top of that, there are the potential minor
reactions so many can have from the vaccine
itself, when a given person may have never
become infected with the flu anyway, even
had they not been vaccinated- essentially
causing them pain and discomfort for no net
benefit to themselves.
For these reasons, opponents of the flu vaccine
sometimes note that it is inappropriate for
any governmental organization to recommend
or require its citizens to get a flu vaccine.
On the other side of the argument, proponents
of the flu vaccine point out that, aside from
washing your hands and covering your mouth
when you cough, vaccination is the best way
we have at preventing the massive number of
hospitalizations and deaths that occur each
year as a result of the flu- and that’s
with us already benefiting from a level of
herd immunity from current vaccination levels.
In the extreme case of getting rid of flu
vaccinations altogether, as some anti-vaccers
propose, the problem would be much worse-
in the worst case scenario perhaps even someday
resembling such historic incidents as the
1918 flu pandemic when about 1 in 20 people
(yep) on planet Earth died as a result of
said flu outbreak (a strain of H1N1 influenza),
with about 1 in 4 of the human population
contracting the virus.
(This pandemic was so severe that another
one that struck around the same time went
largely unnoticed by the wider world despite
killing a whopping 1 million people and affecting
countless others, including leaving many trapped
inside their own bodies, without the will
to speak or move.
Just as quickly as the disease appeared, it
suddenly seemed to disappear, leaving the
medical world completely stumped.
It was only about a decade ago that researchers
finally uncovered what seems to have caused
the problem- a disease that’s actually still
around today- a rare form of streptococcus-
and whose symptoms start with a simple sore
throat.
For you hypochondriacs out there, try not
to dwell on that one the next time you get
strep-throat.
For more on all this, see our article The
Mysterious Encephalitis Lethargica Epidemic.)
In the end, even given current flu vaccines’
less than ideal effectiveness rates, the reason
so many health organizations recommend everyone
within certain age groups get the flu vaccine
every year is that we as a society have the
ability to relatively cheaply save many thousands
of additional lives per year world wide on
top of what is already saved via widespread
flu vaccination.
The main cost here is a significantly smaller
number potentially having serious reactions
and the rest merely suffering a mild inconvenience
or no issues at all as a result of the vaccine-
thus, in the vast majority of cases a tiny
price to pay for saving so many people’s
lives every year.
Of course, opponents of flu vaccines argue
that those precious handful pay the ultimate
price in saving the lives of a much greater
number each year- like the lotto, it probably
won’t be you that “wins,” but somebody
will.
Someday, the occasional heroes that are the
beaker-geeks of the world might be able to
create a universal flu vaccine to prevent
all types of influenza viruses from causing
their meshwork of mayhem- perhaps not long
after even ridding the world of this occasional
plague of humanity altogether, as humanity
has done with smallpox.
Until that day, there will undoubtedly be
controversy surrounding the flu vaccine, particularly
when mandatory flu vaccination programs are
occasionally pushed.
Before you decide to take the plunge on one
side or the other, make sure you talk to your
doctor and get the specifics of your situation-
some may have good reason not to get such
a vaccine, such as those already immunocompromised
from illness or disease.
But for most everyone else, it might hurt
a little to receive a flu vaccine, but it
also should help- if not you, perhaps an individual
of the particularly youthful or elderly persuasion
you care about.
It’s been theorized that the eradication
of smallpox and the rapid rise of HIV around
the same time was no coincidence.
Both HIV and smallpox exploit the same receptor
(CCR5) and, interestingly enough, the vaccine
for smallpox has been shown to provide some
protection against HIV as well.
Thus, when the masses suddenly stopped being
commonly vaccinated for smallpox, it made
it easier
for HIV to spread.